[Música]
hola bienvenidos a la crónica de medio
ambiente de france 24 soy maría clara
calle por marina colorado hoy hablaremos
del acuerdo de escazú y de cómo después
de tres años de su creación
entró en vigor tal como ocurrió el día
de la tierra el pasado 22 de abril este
es el primer acuerdo ambiental de
américa latina y del caribe y que además
es el primero en todo el mundo que habla
de los defensores del medio ambiente
el acuerdo de escazú está basado en tres
pilares el derecho para acceder a la
información ambiental la participación
pública para tomar decisiones y la
justicia en asuntos ambientales por eso
organizaciones como amnistía
internacional la cepal y la onu
respaldaron el tratado
a medida que continuamos abordando los
devastadores impactos del hobbit 19 e
intensificamos los esfuerzos para frenar
la triple crisis del cambio climático el
colapso de la biodiversidad y la
contaminación del medio ambiente natural
la entrada en vigor del acuerdo de
escazú brinda esperanzas e inspiración y
prepara el escenario para la
recuperación sostenible y resiliente al
adoptar un enfoque basado en los
derechos fomentar la creación de
capacidad y la cooperación y centrarse
en los más vulnerables este tratado
regional es un gran paso hacia adelante
en la creación de caminos
transformadores para las personas y
nuestro planeta a pesar del respaldo
internacional el camino para aprobar el
pacto fue ardua los primeros pasos
llegaron en la conferencia de la onu
sobre el desarrollo sostenible en 2012
en río de janeiro o río 20 allí surgió
un único acuerdo vinculante que fue el
acuerdo de escazú
el pacto se basó en el principio 10 de
la declaración de río de janeiro de 1992
que esencialmente habla de
que todos los ciudadanos tienen el
derecho a conocer la información de los
proyectos que pueden amenazar el medio
ambiente como explotaciones mineras o
petroleras durante cuatro años chile y
costa rica lideraron la discusión para
que los países latinos suscribieron el
tratado hasta que en marzo de 2018
lograron adoptar el acuerdo de escazú y
en septiembre de ese mismo año los
países comenzaron a afirmarlo el
problema es que muchos le dieron la
espalda paradójicamente uno de ellos fue
chile porque alegó que el texto que
defendió en un principio tenía
ambigüedades el problema del caso como
señora hasta la forma en que quedó quitó
el texto final dado la ambigüedad y
actitud que quedaron redactados algunos
de sus artículos sumado al carácter
supra legal que se aplica por sobre toda
la legislación nacional así como el
hecho de que no permita hacer ningún
tipo de reserva lo que genera una grave
incertidumbre jurídica en cuanto a la
legislación interna aplicar de los 33
países de américa latina y el caribe 24
firmaron el acuerdo de escazú
pero la rúbrica no es suficiente para
que el acuerdo se pueda aplicar es
necesario que por lo menos 11 países lo
ratifiquen y ese fue un nuevo tropiezo
porque muchos de los que lo firmaron no
lo quisieron ratificar como pasó con
costa rica esto dejó en pausa el acuerdo
de escazú durante dos años y solo hasta
el 2020 se lograron los mínimos
necesarios cuando el senado de méxico
aprobó la ratificación en noviembre de
ese año dos meses después el país se
unió formalmente al tratado y se
alcanzaron los 11 países
estos son los 12 estados de américa
latina y el caribe que hasta ahora han
ratificado el acuerdo de escazú los
últimos países en suscribirse en enero
de 2021 fueron méxico y argentina con lo
que el pacto internacional pudo entrar
en vigor pero el acuerdo de escazú no se
puede aplicar en todo el continente de
hecho los países más peligrosos para los
defensores ambientales todavía no lo han
suscrito según el más reciente reporte
de la organización global witness en
américa latina' están
de los siete países donde más líderes de
la tierra y el ambiente fueron
asesinados en 2019 colombia encabeza la
lista en todo el mundo con 64 líderes
asesinados seguido en la región por
brasil méxico y honduras que además fue
el país per cápita más peligroso
finalmente de sant guatemala y venezuela
ninguno de ellos excepto méxico han
ratificado el acuerdo de escazú a pesar
de que los defensores ambientales lo
piden
no a esta capacidad creo que tenemos una
gran capacidad de defender el medio
ambiente y los derechos humanos a través
de nuestras herramientas de justicia
pero necesitamos ampliar las esa era la
esperanza que teníamos con el acuerdo de
escazú porque une dos aspectos que
siempre son mencionados como algo
diferente y no lo son la defensa de la
persona que protege al medio ambiente y
el medio ambiente en sí el acuerdo de
escazú hace muy bien eso por eso
necesitamos ratificar el acuerdo
de tres años los precios del hospital
en muchos países miran con recelo que
deben abrir la información de los
proyectos que podrían afectar el medio
ambiente y en varios lugares los
empresarios tuvieron un papel
protagonista para oponerse pero lo que
nos preocupa es que hay un lobby
empresarial que está un poquito
preocupado pensando que este acuerdo de
escazú les va a impedir seguir adelante
y yo les diría que no deberían verlo así
porque en el fondo cuando las
comunidades están en contra de un
proyecto con acuerdo de escaso o sin
acuerdo de escazú no lo van a dejar
pasar y la inversión se va a perder como
ha pasado ya en algunos mega proyectos
en américa latina' de proyectos este
acuerdo lo que dice es consulta previa o
sea pues consulten a las comunidades
pues denle participación y con este
llamado a que más países latinos y
caribeños ratifiquen el acuerdo de
escazú terminamos nuestro programa
recuerden que pueden ver todas las
crónicas de medio ambiente en france24
punto com hasta la próxima
[Música]